كتله الله بهذا نعم انه ليس قد يسكت في
السعوديه ومياه البحار تبدل لونها الى
الاسود الارض تتصدى والتشققات في ارض
الاسكندريه تظهر في اكثر من مكان رائحه
الخوف تسكن صدور اهل مصر وعالم جيولوجيا
مصريه يصرخ ويحذر من امكانيه تعرض بلاده
لزلازل مدمره لنعد بالزمن للخلف قليلا
جفاف وامطار شبه منعدمه وارتفاع في درجه
الحراره في اوروبا والانهار تجف لب الارض
يتوقف عن الدوران ويغيروا مساره وقد تشرق
الشمس من الغرب الجميع يضحك بسخريه ليصحو
على فاجعه رح ضحيتها اكثر من 20000 قتيل
ونقصد زلزاله تركيا وسوريا التحذيرات لدول
البحر المتوسط من شبح تسونامي قادم الخوف
يسيطر على العالم والكل يترقب النهايه
بصمت هل هذه رسائل تحذيريه للبشر في نهايه
العالم وهل تتعرض مصر لموجه تسونامي
وزلزال مدمر وما علاقه سد النهضه الاثيوبي
بدخول مصر قائمه الخطر لتعرف اجابه كل تلك
الاسئله عليك مشاهده دقائق الفيديو القادم
طلوع الشمس من مغربها
اجتاحت حاله من الهلع الشديد سكان العالم
عندما اعلن باحثون الصينيون اواخر يناير
الماضي ان لب الارض الداخلي قد توقف عن
الدوران بشكل مؤقت وانه من المنتظر ان
يستانف لب الارض الدوران مره اخرى ولكنه
سيدور في الاتجاه المعاكس ليذهب الكثير من
البشر الى القول بان الامر بدايه لدوران
الارض في اتجاه المعاكس وبالتالي ستشرق
الشمس من مغربها الظاهره التي تعتبر احدى
علامات الساعه الكبرى والتي ستنتهي بعدها
بوقت قليل الحياه البشريه على الارض وتدخل
البشريه بعدها بوقت قصير في مرحله مرعبه
مرح الحساب الالهي ورغم تاكيدات الخبراء
بان الامر لا علاقه له بطلوع الشمس من
المغرب اصر عدد كبير من البشر على انه
بدايه لعلامات الساعه الكبرى متوقعين
كوارث اخرى ستحدث في الارض قريبا ولم تمر
ايام قليله لتشهد تركيا وسوريا الزلزالا
مدمرا راح ضحيته اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين الف
قتيل حتى الان بالاضافه لعشرات الالاف من
المصابين وانهيار الاف المباني كما شعر به
سكان باقي الدول المنطقه مثل اليونان
ولبنان والاردن ومصر التي شهدت هي الاخرى
ظاهره مرعبه وسط تحذيرات من تعرضها لموجه
تسونامي مدمره فهل مصر بعيده عن وقوع
زلزال مدمر وهل هي على موعد مع موجه
تسونامي مصر وزلازل المدمره تسبب زلزال
تركيا المدمر في قلق كبير للمسؤولين في
مصر ورغم تاكيدات عديده بان مصر تقع في
منطقه امنه الزلازل المدمره تحركت الحكومه
المصريه لتنشئ محطات جديده لرصد الزلازل
بالاضافه الى المحطات الموجوده مسبقا
ليزيد عدد المحطات رصد الزلازل في مصر الى
مئه بدلا من 70 محطه ولكن يبدو ان مصر
ليست في مامن تام من الزلازل المدمره فقد
حذر الباحث البيئي الاردني احمد ملاعبه من
ان مصر والسودان ستكونان عرضه لزلزال
المدمر والسبب في ذلك هو سد النهضه
الاثيوبي والذي كان سببا في تعرض الدولتين
لبعض الزلازل الخفيفه في الاونه الاخيره
وعلى اثيوبيا ان توقف مشروع السد في اقرب
وقت خصوصا وانه يشكل تهديدا كبيرا لمصر
والسودان ولاثيوبيا نفسها فحجم خزان السد
الضخم يؤدي الى ترشيح المياه وتاثير على
التربه والقشره الارضيه بل وحتى على الارض
بالكامل والذي سيكون السبب الرئيسي في
حدوث الزلزال فهل تقتنع اثيوبيا بالخطر
وتوقف مشروع السد
وموجه تسونامي قامت الحكومه التركيه
بتحذير دول البحر المتوسط من تعرضها لموجه
تسونامي قادمه والتي ستكون ضمن توابع
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
لتدب حاله من الهلع في سكان المناطق
الساحليه خوفا من كارثه تسونامي ولكن بعد
تحليل البيانات الخاصه بزلزال تركيا الغت
الحكومه التركيه التحذير وبالتالي لن
تتعرض مدن دول البحر المتوسط لموجات
تسونامي ورغم ذلك لم تكن مصر بعيده عن
الخطر فما الذي حدث في مصر هبوط ارضي ولون
مياه اسود
لم تمر ساعات على زلزال تركيا الا وشهدت
مصر ظاهرتين مرعبتين ففي نفس اليوم شهدت
مدينه الاسكندريه هبوطا ارضيا عنيفا في
كورنيش احد شواطئها بالاضافه الى العديد
من التشققات الارضيه والتي اثارت حاله من
الهلع بين سكان المدينه الذين ربطوا
التشققات والهبوط الارضي بزلزال تركيا
لتتحرك الحكومه المصريه من اجل اصلاح
الارض وكرنيش الاسكندريه مؤكده من خلال
خبرائها ان الظاهره لا علاقه لها بزلزال
تلك المدمر وانما هي نتيجه للامطار
الغزيره التي هطلت على المدينه اثناء
تعرضها لنوه الكرم ولكن بعد ثلاثه ايام من
تلك الواقعه كانت الاسكندريه على موعد مع
ظاهره مرعبه اخرى فقد فوجئ سكان المدينه
بتحول لون مياه البحر الى الاسود الامر
الذي تسبب فيها لاعب السكان وتم تصوير
الظاهره الغريبه بفيديو تداوله نشطاء
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي معلقين عليه
بجمله هل هو من اثار زلزال تلك المدمر ام
غضبا من الله وحتى الان لا تزال مياه بحر
الاسكندريه يغطيها اللون الاسود وسط حاله
من الخوف تابت سكان المدينه دون معرفه
السبب الحقيقي لتلك الظاهره المرعبه حتى
الان
زلزال فلسطين لم تسلم من الاحداث المرعبه
والتي حدثت في الاونه الاخيره بمناطق
متفرقه من العالم فمنذ ايام شهدت مدينه
نابلس العديد من الهزات الارضيه والتي
تراوحت قوتها بين ثلاثه واربعه درجات على
مقياس ريختار ولعلك تقول ان تلك الدرجات
تعد خفيفه جدا اذا ما قارنت بما حدث
بتركيا ولكن الامر بالنسبه للسكان نابلس
اكثر رعبا مما تظن فابنيه المدينه ليست
حديثه بل ان معظمها مبني بالطرق البسيطه
وبالتالي ستكون تلك الابنيه اول ضحايا اي
زلزال عنيف يضرب المدينه وما حدث منذ ايام
عاد للاذهان الزلزال العنيفه الذي ضرب
نابلس اواخر عشرينيات القرن الماضي والذي
خلف وراءه 300 قتيل وانهيار مئات المباني
بالمدينه
سقوط نيزك في السعوديه حتى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لم تسلم من الاحداث
المرعبه التي تتوالى على الارض فمنذ يومين
احد النيازك الغلاف الجوي للارض ليسقط على
محافظه ادوات شمال غرب مدينه
الريريرها فيديو وقاموا بنشر الفيديو على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مؤكدين انهم قد
سمعوا صوت ذوي لسقوط النيزك على الارض قرب
مدينهم ورغم ان الواقعه لم ينتج عنها اي
ضحايا الا انها تسببت في العديد من
التساؤلات حول الاحداث الغريبه والغامضه
التي مرت بالمنطقه العربيه في الاونه
الاخيره ولا تزال تمر بها حتى الان
نهايه الحياه على الارض
رغم ان مساله قيام الساعه ونهايه الحياه
على الارض لطالما شغلت عقول كل البشر في
مختلف العصور الا ان مصطلح نهايه العالم
قد ظهر الان كثيرا على السطح اكثر من اي
وقت مضى فالاحداث التي وقعت منذ عده اشهر
ولا تزال مستمره جعلت البشر يؤكدون انها
من علامات الساعه وان النهايه قد اقتربت
ففي السنه الماضيه فوجئ العالم العربي
بهطول امطار غزيره وسيول على صحراء الربع
الخالي اكثر المناطق جفافا على وجه الارض
يتم ربط الواقعه بحديث النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم والذي اكد فيه ان قيام الساعه
مرتبط بتحول جزيره العرب لمروج وانهار
لتاتي بعد ذلك انباء عن دوران لب الارض
الداخلي في اتجاه معاكس ما يعني عكس دوران
الارض وشروق الشمس من مغربها ليلحق هذا
الخبر بايام قليله زلزال تركيا وسوريا
المدمر وزلزال مدينه نابلس بفلسطين تبعهم
هبوطا ارضيا بمدينه الاسكندريه والتي تحول
لون مياه بحرها الى اللون الاسود ولا يزال
الحزن يخيم على العالم باكمله وسط مخاوف
من اقتراب نهايه العالم وانتهاء الحياه
البشريه على كوكب الارض والان هل ترى ان
كل تلك الكوارث تعني اقتراب الساعه ونهايه
الحياه البشريه ام ان الامر ليس له علاقه
بنهايه العالم